[Music]
this is StarTalk sports edition things
you thought you knew yeah got Gary Riley
Gary hey Neil all right Chuck Nice my
co-hosts here hey what's happening all
right guys guys so we're gonna do some
explaining today uh-huh and I want to
talk about the exit velocity of home
runs in baseball
you know now that they can report this
information they do you mean like when
you hit a baseball into space
so that would be escape velocity
oh okay yeah nobody nobody's done that
yet not even yeah I was gonna say how
many steroids does it take to make that
happen
be up there in the space station and
baseball goes by so back to exit
velocity so they've been tracking this
so a couple of interesting things to
consider
um the you know they're typically to get
out of the stadium the ball has to leave
the bat depends on the angle of course
but has to lead the bat anywhere between
90 and 120 miles an hour
um and depending on the angle many of
them that I've seen are between like 95
five and 110 miles an hour but you can
easily pop home runs at 100 miles an
hour exit velocity but I have an issue
I have an issue okay
only way to get the velocity of the ball
is to use a Doppler phenomenon on it you
use a Doppler speed gun basically what
the cops use when they fire microwaves
at you wait for the return signal see
how much it has Doppler shifted and then
they can calculate all right based on
the speed of the light and the return
signal how fast you were going and it'll
do that for how fast the baseball was
going here's the problem
you only get the correct speed
if you are looking exactly in the
direction the ball is coming
you are at any angle to that you will
measure a lesser speed than the actual
ball is moving and if you and if you are
if you are sideways to it
the speed you're going to measure is
zero because the ball is neither coming
towards you or away from you it's not
reflecting any light back to you well uh
in the direction it's moving correct
right in the direction it's moving okay
so I do not know how they are getting
the actual velocity of the ball
after it leaves the bat which would
require okay A a
um
one of the
radar measurement radar guns in the
exact line of the ball itself
okay so one of these would have to be
mounted in the catcher's groin looking
up at the pool or something by the way
it just made me want to watch baseball
because I want to know what's happening
with the groin cam the groin cam I'm all
about the growing Camp okay
so for a camera or a radar gun floating
in the middle of the stadium in the air
in the direction that the ball is hit so
that the measurement
is along the sight line of the camera
itself which is why the person measuring
the speed of the pitcher sits behind
home plate behind the screen okay
they're in the exact line all right and
which is why if a cop stops you and
they're not directly in front of you on
the road you're black
okay uh yes I'm pretty sure I clocked
you at 90 miles an hour uh bro you were
no you weren't even here what are you
talking about you were sitting in the
rest stop what are you saying
all right so all right go ahead go ahead
so point is uh I I don't know how
they're getting the velocity off the bat
unless they're measuring it straight on
if they're measuring it straight on
then they're getting the wrong speed but
then they have to measure the angle okay
now here's another issue I have
the angle they're giving it
is the angle the ball is leaving the bat
with the horizontal
okay all right all right was it 10
degrees up 20 30 for but that's not the
angle that matters here
they're doing it wrong okay
okay that's okay that's not the because
the angle of the bat is swung at
okay
that's that's the factor in here somehow
so here's what here's something we know
in physics
if you want to send an object a
projectile as far as possible from where
you're standing you want to throw it at
a 45 degree angle
which is exactly midway between 0 and
90. right in that way all the energy
that lifts it equals all the energy that
propels it
okay right and that way neither one nor
the other sort of wins out thereby
carrying the ball as far as it possibly
can go that is not the farthest home run
if you hit it at 45 degrees here's the
problem if I swing the bat horizontally
as you're trained in in little league
right good level swing okay
and the ball goes up
at like a 45 degree angle let's say
all right
some of the speed of your bat
went to send the ball forward and some
went to send the ball upwards okay
the net speed
is of the ball is less than that of your
bet
okay
and we can know exactly what this it
would be the square root of two would be
uh one divided by the square root of two
okay if you do the math on that okay
okay but it comes from the right
triangles in your what you took in
eighth grade okay okay that's the math
that's in this
and you were probably thinking Chuck I
will never need to know this
okay yeah it's so good to know that this
has an application
in
baseball
I'm sure no one's sitting in the in the
stance just like hmm
if only I could remember my euclidean
math
oh nice
[Laughter]
write that down on your stack card
listen
your back speed is only in the plane in
which you are swinging the bat
yep okay
so
if you are swinging in the limit
horizontally
and the ball comes off at a 45 degree
angle you did not impart all the
velocity of the bat to the ball
okay okay all right so the question is
how do you maximize
the velocity of the bat to be imparted
into the exit velocity of the ball
uh you get your GM to sign Aaron judge
and that's so the only way to do this
but they're not going to do it I'll tell
you why in a minute is to swing at a 45
degree angle
then
then
the 110 mile an hour moving bat will
will send the ball at 110 miles per hour
at 40 at a 45 degree angle
all of the speed of the Bat gets
imparted to the ball
sometimes it looks like that happens
when you see like these power hitters
kind of it looks like they go down and
dig the ball up yes so so what they're
doing from the angles I've seen is
they're swinging for the ball to go
about 30 degrees up
okay 45 there's like it is no they're
not doing 45 degrees 30 degrees with
that power Slugger you know down and up
those are coming in closer to 20 to 30
degrees angle in so doing 100 of the bat
speed is transmitted to the ball
and at 30 degrees even though that's not
the best angle
it is the best combination of angle and
speed given the configuration of what's
going on at home plate
okay does any of this make sense so okay
now here's the problem
if you try to hit the ball
at a 45 degree angle
but the ball is coming in horizontally
that's really hard
because what's the limit of that the
limit of that is let's say you want to
swing vertically up at the ball as it
goes by
what are the chances of you succeeding
at that okay
90 miles an hour and you're trying to
chop at it to chop at it okay okay so
the steeper is your angle that you're
swinging relative to the angle of the
pitch coming in makes it harder to make
contact with the ball
and a 45 degree angle that's that would
be really hard to do that
so you want at least some of the bets
playing to overlap the plane of the
pitched ball
okay so that you make some kind of
contact at all
so when you combine a swing that's up at
an angle but not 45 degrees but
definitely not horizontal because you're
not getting your full speed out of that
you combine that with a slugger who's
moving his Bat at 120 110 miles an hour
the ball comes in and there it goes off
at 110 miles an hour you've got it
and there's your home run but I can tell
you if batteries manage to make contact
at a 45 degree angle they'd hit the ball
600 feet
wow so in summary uh it's not realistic
to swing the bat at a 45 degree angle
right it's very hard to hit a moving
Target that way so you pick a lower
angle such as 30 degrees that still
gives you a good chance of making
contact with the ball
and most of the bat speed will be
transmitted to the ball okay to the
forward motion of the ball and if you
swing the bat at
120 miles an hour let's say at the point
of contact yeah with the ball a 30
degree angle
uh if you swing horizontally and it goes
up at a 30 degree angle the cosine of 30
is 0.86 the round that off to 0.9 so the
ball is still hit with 90 percent of the
speed of your bat
um so you're still you're still doing
well there and if you increase the angle
just a little bit then all the bat speed
goes to the ball and the ball is
launched at your bat speed and I I'm
still a question what numbers they're
using in baseball
so I think what we have learned here
is that any other grass Tyson is the
only person that can have this
conversation at a baseball field
measuring is not the angle the ball is
with the field they should be measuring
the angle of the ball takes off from the
swing plane of the bat
okay and that will tell you how much
speed is not going to the ball that the
bat had on contact
okay because when the angle is 90
degrees there's no forward speed going
to the ball it's a straight pop-up back
to the catcher all right no so that so
you can learn a lot that way by by
getting these numbers accurate and tell
me the angle at which the batter swung
the bat
I want to know that too okay so what we
need to do is put a request out to our
audience who are incredibly
knowledgeable and say do you have the
answer to Neil's question how are these
metrics how is this data being captured
and if needs be come and speak to Neil
and uh yeah I don't think that they're
doing it right I don't see how they
could possibly be doing it
um and and I think the angle it's not
the interesting angle the angle to the
horizontal it's the angle to the bad
that's a way more and and so what angle
do you want the ball to come off the bat
with you tell me right now after this
conversation
45 degrees no no back of the class for
me
what angle do you want it to come off
the bat
relative to the plane that you swung at
come off the bat relative to I want it
to come off the bat straight off the bat
thank you zero degrees off zero degrees
okay right off the bat if I'm swinging
at 30 degrees the ball is also coming
off at 30 degrees 30 degrees at all of
my bat speed goes to the ball right
that's what you get so Chuck you move
gold star on the wall
Gary Gary you come to my office hours
later yeah I get it all right that's all
I got to say about Pitch balls and
angled you hit and all of that so uh
here's the uh takeaway people uh Major
League Baseball is lying to you no I
think I think they are lying I think
they're being they're being zealous in
their ability to measure so then they
put it they measure everything right and
they're thinking they're getting it
right and and it's not okay so I think
there's more to be refined in that
exercise that they've conducted in the
sport I love data who doesn't love data
and so we'll see what what the future of
these measurements bring to not only the
fan appreciation but managerial
decisions uh stop lying MLB yes
I applaud the effort okay okay all right
it's been another Star Talk explainer
the sports edition Edition
Neil deGrasse Tyson keep looking up
[Music]